selon vous le travail difficile les
hommes est ce que le travail du viso les
hommes je pourrais dire que on a deux
parties oui oui et non un travail
difficile les jeunes n'ont pas forcément
le travail divise style elle les hommes
à scie le sujet inspire moyennement les
yvelinois ils étaient plus de 20 mille
candidats de la filière économique et
sociale dans les yvelines devoir s'y
pencher ce lundi matin lundi 17 juin
l'ouverture de la nouvelle session du
baccalauréat par la traditionnelle
épreuve de philosophie
juste après ma cour j'essaie de
comprendre parce que pour moi la
philosophie va comprendre par là contre
parker se sert à rien à part les
définitions on a plus l'impression de
pas être assez préparé donc en croise
les doigts et on croit la bonne chance
parmi les autres sujets proposés elle
les lois peuvent elles faire notre
bonheur où la pluralité des cultures
fait l obstacle à l'unité du genre
humain
ce que j'ai sous les yeux c'est le sujet
ds très beau sujet vraiment ces trois
sujets j'aurais eu du banat à choisir
entre les trois sont vraiment des
belles choses avec des diversités fin
des sujets qui sont divers qui font
appel à des références très variés et
sur lesquels je pense que les élèves
peuvent vraiment faire d excellente
copie 70 1944 candidates et candidats se
présentent dans les yvelines au
baccalauréat dont un peu moins de 30000
dans les séries technologiques et
professionnelles et après 4 heures
d'épreuve la confiance le dispute comme
toujours au soulagement ça s'est bien
passé
naturellement ça va je pense qu'il me
suis bien débrouillé après c'est vrai
qu'on l'a appréhendé la philo ça tient
mon est bon la philo c'est pas quelque
chose de simple donc forcément on a dû
faire avec mais franchement je pense que
ça s'est bien passé
franchement ça va il était facile mais
mon prof m'a dit je vois pas plus de 8
rebonds chemisier mais je pensais bonnes
notes froid de la philo prochaine
épreuve l'histoire-géographie mardi
matin suivis par les langues mercredi
résultats attendus le 5 juillet